en janvier et en février dernier la grc
a intercepté 3092 migrants parce qu'ils
avaient franchi illégalement la
frontière des etats-unis vers le canada
et 95% ces arrestations ont eu lieu au
québec une téléspectatrice nous ont
demandé pourquoi presque tous les
migrants sont arrêtés en territoire
québécois
[Musique]
six migrants clandestins décide de
passer par le québec
c'est essentiellement pour des raisons
géographiques si vous voulez rentrer
clandestinement au canada par le nouveau
brunswick
il devrait d'abord traversé une immense
forêt en ontario et des faut savoir que
l'ontario est séparé des états unis
presque entièrement par de l'eau pour y
en a près clandestinement il fonda non
nagées ou avoir un bateau dans les
prairies les distances entre les centres
urbains sont énormes
il fait souvent très froid d'ailleurs
une migrante qui tentaient d'entrer au
canada par le manitoba est morte de
froid en plein mois de mai plus à
l'ouest bien sûr il ya les montagnes il
reste un secteur de la frontière
terrestre qui est accessible en colombie
britannique
mais comme la plupart des migrants qui
viennent des états unis pensent d'abord
par des grandes villes de la côte est
comme new york
mais le choix d'entrer par le québec
devient assez logique mais une fois
entré qui a la responsabilité des
demandeurs d'asile il faut savoir qu'en
vertu d'une convention internationale
signée en 1951 le canada au l'obligation
de s'occuper des demandeurs d'asile
du moins le temps de traiter leurs
dossiers même s'ils sont rentrés
illégalement au pays durant cette
période
le fédéral a la responsabilité de
traiter dossiers gérés l'octroi de
permis de travail est payé pour des
soins de santé la province de son côté
doit gérer l'hébergement donner accès à
l'éducation primaire pour les enfants et
fournir de l'aide sociale mais plus il y
aune migrants plus les délais de
traitement sont longs à ottawa plus ça
coûte cher en particulier au québec
parce que comme on l'a vu la plupart des
migrants clandestins passe d'abord par
le québec et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement québécois réclame depuis
mars dernier une aide financière de 146
millions de dollars au gouvernement
fédéral